the own it's great to have you here at
London Film I'm coming home today we
course we've met you before and we know
when you were filming Merlin in France
you ended up being a bit of a tourist
attraction you guys what was that like I
think we made France a better place just
to just in general and a friend now yeah
I wished in the French government could
like giving us little medals and stuff
no I don't think they really cared very
much and yeah France is mental because
there's so many he was a lot of people
and it was it can be a little bit and
sometimes it's a bit like doing a
theater play I said because you're kind
of on show a lot when you're doing all
the scenes outside so it's very much
you're being watched that the film is
quite intimate and televisions quite
into it because there only is
interviewed big crew so that was much
more about almost a live performance
type thing in a way yeah now there's a
bit of a rumor going around that the
guys spent longer in the makeup truck
than the ladies did on Merlin and we
spoke to refit recently and he said oh
yeah it sounds right right but I'm gonna
say no because I don't want that rumor
to continue but what do you say weld it
well it's actually a lot of bollocks
I'll be honest with you they didn't
really I didn't have a gut make of
Merlin very very rarely I love to make
up girls we didn't really do anything so
I think Rupert Rupert Anna takes quite a
while to scrape fluffy and curly you
know my just get out of a shower under
the sits like this you know Rupert's the
main culprit
you're watching go kind of go wash and
go kind of go yeah I'm not into makeup
so dirt they give me loads of dirt I
like getting dirt for them yeah
that's good now you had more and more
armor as you went on on the show as well
what was that like were you weighed down
you know I I actually hated that because
I'm when I first came in I didn't have
any armor was just like all these nice
kind of airy-fairy clothes and then I
began to be a very jealous of Merlin
because he had no armor and I remember
when I first came in I had the same
costume as he did essentially and then I
began to get quite envious the fact that
he was still jumping around the place
and just like nice little woolen boots
and little kind of you know leggings and
nice looking a t-shirt I said this isn't
fair we're rocking with France and capes
and and all sorts of armor and this
isn't intense yeah really was okay I
gotta ask this name how do you think
your skills on the following things
improved over the various seasons you do
Merlin okay
riding horses having sword fights
getting drunk and getting lost in
forests well exponentially they all got
better I think they're getting lost and
forests got worse as a thing as in you
don't get better getting lost in price
get worse getting awesome for us the
rest of all got better though as a
read-along yeah you were still facing
proved John then yes apart from part
from the getting lost part yeah we've
talked a bit about with either guys what
would happen if it was a Merle in the
movie would you be up for going Matt
from early in the movie and what would
you like to see in am i I'd happily do
run a movie but I mean it depends on how
they wrote it what they did with it
so by I don't really know I yeah I guess
if they were gonna do and I do it ya
know Stefan but I'd like I do an
adventures Gwaine inventions the Green
Knight Knoll not gonna serve every fun
to do
I'm gonna ask you a bit about cold as
well because I see you've um one of your
new movie you've crowdfunded it how's
that going with that and won't quit
expect to see it and tell us a bit about
it well well we're finished it and I
sprained wearing a go away in next
Saturday asleep and going to the main
screen which I'm really happy bear so
got one the main picks and I go always
the festivals close to my heart and then
we're going to work out from go away
what festivals are going to send it to
afterwards so it's it's really really
beautiful rehab words hopefully all I
want to do the festival circuit with it
for six months now we're just kind of
see what happens but it's it's finished
and everyone's so far the feedbacks been
great so many happy what's it like
working with Tom as the director as well
as an actor and the writer on this one
as well but Tom's release to were quick
cuz he's just he's Tom isn't he he's
just like the easiest press in the world
so it's like you know just like hanging
out more plants and more films after
this one then I'm doing a I'm doing a
show on NBC called a night shift and we
start shooting in about five weeks so
I'm not thinking about that I'm just
writing a lot I've written a book and a
few other things I'm just kind of
working a lot so you character on that
of adrenaline junkie isn't he and a
rule-breaker
how much been adrenaline junkie and a
rule breaker do you think you are
depends on what it is and I'm not gonna
go do nay that crazy stuff like doing
stunts on a on a motorbike out of a
helicopter but I like I like doing my
own stuff yeah I don't like being told
what to do
so maybe the similarities that way and
the doctors on the shows I've had a bit
of pranksters as well how much your
pranks are you reckon you are and what
your favorite prank that you've ever
done do you know I have a feeling we're
going to put a lot of pranks in the show
because the other guys are a bit mental
and Jo and Brendan and it kind of a I
get the feeling work this and this show
could be fun
in terms of we're gonna get in trouble
it's like that's the impression I get
oh it is good let me speak into you
enjoy the rest today absolutely I say
listen
you